is the experience of New Orleans can you
replicate that because part of that was
because of Hurricane Katrina wiping out
the existing literally wiping out the
existing school infrastructure cannot be
done in a less disastrous circumstances
yeah you know I think we sort of focus
on the wrong reason why New Orleans is
successful and we tend to think it's
Katrina but what it really was was we
had a system that was utterly failed for
so long that people were fed up and what
Katrina did was it allowed us to think
differently about what we could have so
you could be in st. Louis Missouri and
you could decide that we've had enough
and they did and the state took those
schools over just like we took over in
New Orleans now how we took them over
and what we did with them is a little
bit different than what's going on in
other so we really have relied on this
more competitive model more
decentralized model and we think that
that will drive what what is the biggest
what is the biggest obstacle to further
decentralizing like the control of the
education system and empowering parents
well you know there's some real
practical problems just give you an
example in a school district that has
say six schools and you take one or two
of those schools and convert them to a
charter school and you take all the
money that goes with those kids and give
it to those charter schools you
necessarily deplete the district's
ability to manage the other four schools
because the money part of the money that
goes to those charter schools now does
not go to the central office overhead so
districts are afraid that when you start
creating this competitive environment
that they'll go out of business and my
answer is they will go out of business
as we know it but they need to find new
ways of doing their business and doing
what's really important for the other
four schools